[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein ganz
besonderes video denn ich zeige euch wie
ihr kummrow selber herstellt combo ist
der neue fast food trend aus der türkei
besser gesagt aus es mit und dort war
ich diesem sommer habt den kongo mal
probiert und ich war hin und weg und 12
klar den muss ich zu hause selber machen
[Musik]
hugo ist ein üppig belegte sesam
brötchen mit drei verschiedenen
wurstsorten mit halloumi käse und
tomaten und saure gurken
da wir für unser kummrow zuallererst das
typisch türkisches selbstgemachte sesam
brötchen benötigen zeige ich euch
zuallererst die zutaten dafür das sind
einmal mehr lauwarme milch neutrales öl
ich hab rapsöl verwendet außerdem
geschmolzene butter 1 1 frische hefe und
backpulver außerdem puderzucker und
etwas salz
wir kümmern uns nun zuallererst um die
hefe und dafür geben wir die lauwarme
milch in eine ausreichend große schüssel
und zerbröseln die hefe hinein
[Musik]
damit die frische hefe nahrung hat geben
wir dem puderzucker mit hinzu und rühren
das ganze gut um
[Musik]
nun lassen wir der hefe zehn minuten
zeit zu holen
nachdem zehn minuten geben wir die
restlichen flüssigen zutaten mit hinzu
also einmal das öl die butter die sollte
nicht mehr ganz so heiß sein und das 1
[Musik]
dann werden die zutaten mit dem
schneebesen verrührt bis sich alles gut
verbunden hat
[Musik]
nun kümmern wir uns um die trockenen
zutaten und ich gebe das backpulver und
das salz bereits zum mehl und verrührt
das kurz bevor ich das in die anderen
zutaten mit hinein gebe
[Musik]
in der türkei und wahrscheinlich auch in
einigen anderen ländern hat sich das
schon so etabliert dass man backpulver
und frische hefe als backmittel mit zum
teil gibt denn dann wird der teig
besonders fluffig
nun könnt ihr alles entweder mit den
händen zu einem teig verkneten oder mit
der küchenmaschine beides funktioniert
wunderbar wichtig ist nur dass ihr lang
genug knetet
[Musik]
der tag ist dann super weich und ihr
nehmt ihn am besten aus der schüssel und
knetet ihnen dann noch mal kurz auf der
arbeitsfläche weiter
[Musik]
meine schüsse habe ich noch mal mit
etwas mehl ausgelegt gebe dann den
hefeteig darüber und noch etwas mehr
über den hefeteig und dann muss das
ganze abgedeckt an einem warmen ort
mindestens 45 minuten gehen
[Musik]
bevor wir jetzt mit dem teig
weitermachen zeige ich euch die nächsten
zutaten das sind zum einen trauben sirup
und wasser das traum sirup gebe ich
jetzt direkt zum wasser und das ist ganz
typisch für diese saison brötchen die
kind wahrscheinlich auch diese runden
sesamkringel nämlich sie mit und das ist
ganz typisch dass man diesen süßen
trauben sirup nimmt und die teiglinge
dann erst darin badet und anschließend
in sesam den sesam habe ich mir hier
nämlich auch schon bereitgelegt dass es
umgerüsteter zusammen der wird im ofen
sowieso noch gerüstet
hier seht ihr jetzt meint eick und
schaut mal wie schön der aufgegangen ist
der hat sich ja beinahe verdreifacht und
wenn ihr dann die wartezeit überstanden
habt geht der rest auch ziemlich schnell
den teig knetet jetzt noch mal ganz kurz
zusammen und schneide ihn dann in
gleichmäßig große stücke damit der
übrige teil auch nicht austrocknet legte
ihn immer unter ein tuch um die auch
schön geschützt ist und ein sesam
brötchen so wie ich ihn jetzt hier in
der hand haltung zu einer kugel formen
hat bei mir 180 gramm an gewicht damit
ihr da auch so eine kleine richtlinie
habt sobald ihr dann die kugeln geformt
habt gebt ihr den teig legen auf eure
arbeitsfläche und rollt ihn etwas
längliche aus um ihn dann flach zu
drücken
sobald ihr dann mit eurer ovalen form
zufrieden seid geht ihr euren teig
einmal kurz in den trauben sirup und
welt es anschließend in dem sesam
falls ihr im türkischen supermarkt nach
diesem trauben sirup sucht dann schaut
mal nach husum pack messe ich schreibe
euch den namen aber noch in die infobox
genauso wie alle weiteren zutaten
[Musik]
mit dem teig machen wir dann immer so
weiter bis wir unser backblech voll
haben
ich habe immer sechs sesam brötchen auf
ein backblech gelegt und insgesamt habe
ich übrigens zehn brötchen rausbekommen
ihr müsst nicht alle zur kongo weiter
verarbeiten wir haben einige davon am
nächsten tag noch beim frühstück
gegessen denn sie schmecken am nächsten
tag auch noch sehr lecker
[Musik]
bevor wir sie jetzt in den vorgeheizten
backofen geben schneiden wir noch eine
seite ganz leicht 1 etwa halben
zentimeter und dann werden sie bei 180
grad ober und unterhitze für 30 minuten
gebacken
inzwischen zeige ich euch die zutaten
zum belegen das sind zum einen truthahn
würstchen das sind diese runden die habe
ich einmal in der hälfte durch geteilt
genauso wie hieß zuzog und geflügel
würstchen
desweiteren benötigen wir halloumi das
ist dieser krieg käse der ist super
lecker dann noch saure gurken die ich in
dünne scheiben geschnitten habe und fürs
gute gewissen noch tomaten außerdem ist
es ganz typisch für kummerow noch
mayonnaise und ketchup darüber zu geben
für die geflügel müsst ihn ist es ganz
wichtig dass wir sie vor dem
weiterverarbeiten in hauchdünne scheiben
schneiden
[Musik]
sobald das dann erledigt ist geht es
weiter auf dem herd hier habe ich mir
zwei fanden bereitgelegt in der linken
pfanne habe ich unfair die sedov
scheiben reingelegt und lasse sie jetzt
von beiden seiten anbraten
in der rechten fahne habe ich ein wenig
öl erhitzt das ist neutrales öl und gäbe
da die geflügelwurst hirnschaden hinein
und lassen sie von allen seiten richtig
kross anbraten
da der fettgehalt vom studium sehr hoch
ist benötigt ihr beim anbraten kein
zusätzliches öl und vergisst dann auch
nicht hinterher zu wenden genauso wie
bei den geflügel würstchen
[Musik]
sobald erste job dann fertig ist nämlich
ihn aus der pfanne und hier seht ihr wie
viel fett ausgetreten ist das nutze ich
jetzt einfach und berate darin von
beiden seiten meine truthahn würstchen
an
[Musik]
auch meine geflügel würstchen sind
fertig angebraten die nehme ich jetzt
aus der pfanne und gäbe da die halo mies
mit rein
[Musik]
hallo omi ist übrigens in griechenland
und in ägypten auch sehr bekannt und das
besondere ist dass der käse sich nach
dem erhitzen nicht verformt sondern
formstabil bleibt denkt nur daran dass
sie ihn auch rechtzeitig wendet damit
ihr euch nicht anbrennt nun sind alle
belege perfekt vorbereitet und auch
unsere saison brötchen kommen gerade
frisch aus dem ofen so sehen sie
übrigens fertig gebacken aus nun kann es
losgehen und wir können unser co
fertigstellen
nach welcher reihenfolge er das belegt
ist natürlich vorkommen euch überlassen
hier zeige ich euch meine variante ich
gebe die großen truthahn würstchen ganz
gerne direkt aufs brot gebe darüber dann
die geflügel würstchen und verteile dann
etwas zog darauf darüber kommt dann
reichlich halloumi anschließend etwas
ketchup und mayo und dann wird noch das
gemüse darüber gegeben
[Musik]
danach gebt ihr nur noch den deckel
darüber und euer kummerow ist fertig ich
bin ein absoluter fan und ich bin mir
sicher dass ihr es auch sein sobald ihr
das mal ausprobiert habt falls euch
jetzt auch gerade das wasser im mund
zusammen läuft dann schaut man unten in
die infobox dort stehen alle zutaten
inklusive der mengenangaben und ich
freue mich wenn ihr das ganze mal
ausprobiert und mir dann berichtet wie
es euch geschmeckt hat
[Musik]
ansonsten freue ich mich wenn ihr meinen
kanal abonniert damit ihr auch keines
männer videos mehr verpasst und ich sagt
bis zum nächsten mal okay sketchen